the when when we move we went to Ireland
because of the death death of my little
sister and there were my brother Frank
myself and twin boys Oliver a new gene
and when we got to Ireland we worked
within two years the two boys Eugene and
Oliver died when they were about four
and four and a half of various ailments
at the time that nobody cared too much
for what was going on with poor people
there were no autopsies or anything he
just died of he just died and good
riddance but but when we got there
childress three and a half Frank was
born uh we were known as Yanks and you
feel outside the tribe when you are
speaking differently acting differently
behaving differently so as quickly as
possible you made the attempt to be get
in with the gang talk like them and be
like them and dressed like them so but
no no matter what we did we were still
Yanks so then we grow up there and we
come to America back to America back to
know here and they say oh you're Irish
over there we Yanks over here we're
Irish so my brother Frank and myself
decided a long time ago than what we are
very simply is we are New Yorkers this
is our country this is my land this is
the place for me where every single
dream I ever had came to fruition and I
love it dearly I love you New York
to be Irish in 2010 2010 there's a there
is a pride in our that that's happened
in our intellectual accomplishments and
our literary compliments can accomplish
myths in our technological
accomplishments for here 24 after oh
eight hundred years of occupation and
the function of the oppressor is to
assure you that you are nothing that
you're nobody that you're less than
deserving of nothing that you are a
piece of and don't aspire to
anything and they infuse you with with
shame which has to do with the past
because the all shame is based firmly in
the past it has to do with what you have
done what you thought you have done and
what has sometimes shame is induced by
what has been done to you and by
allowing things to be done to you you're
ashamed of not resisting so that's one
part of oppression is to make sure you
make sure you're a shameful shamed human
being then on the other end that takes
care of the past and the future has to
do with fear don't attempt to come up
here don't attempt to go forward you are
you were nobody you are nobody and
you'll always be nothing so don't even
think about coming here because if you
do something awful will happen to you so
we were we were caught between the two
demons to
shame and fear and we couldn't deal with
the present which was that we are indeed
as accomplished in our own minds as
spiritual as any other people as good as
any other people but we could not look
in the mirror and ever say that that's
that's what we are so to be Irish today
is the abandonment of that shame and the
younger people are moving it out and
they're moving the fear away they're not
afraid their adventurous they're going
about the world as careful not carefree
what carefree I suppose but as with
confidence and with and there with the
knowledge of the language with the
education linguistically capable poetic
and fun-loving with the love of song and
of life itself so that for the younger
people to be is is is a great it's a
wonderful thing that is happening the
older ones of my generation are infused
with fiddler still have the fear and
various ethnic groups have have diseases
that are peculiar to their group and for
example Jewish people have a sax and the
African Americans have a sickle cell
anemia and the the Irish diseases
respectability and that infects them a
lot and there was what would somebody
said I was what would they say what
would the English say if you wore that
said that bead that so consequently as
the Irish poet a he said you eventually
become the thing you hate the most
that's why so many of these yahoos
particularly the ones that run the
center st. Patrick's Day parade are
conservatives and that conservatism is
it's not a political ideology it is a
form severe form of brain damage for
which there's hardly any cure I don't
know what what we can do with them as a
whole but they are gradually moving out
the younger folks are taken over and
someday there may be some culture in
this st. Patrick's Day but I prefer if a
were an Irish parade like Israel Israel
has it as a parade that's Israel not
devoted to Moses or Abraham or st. Moses
of Santa Abraham and so I'd like to see
the day when this was an Irish play
because you can't be grand marshal of
this charade if you're not a Catholic
and they say a practicing Catholic now a
lot of these guys are hypocrites I've
been there about Dara borders practicing
as as I am and I don't certainly am NOT
I observed the whole thing myself but
they are it's hypocritical anyway and I
hope that one day it will be an IR it
would be nice parade then I would march
future if you have if you have one foot
in the future I one foot in the past
you're pissing on the present so I stay
in the present so I don't know about the
future
you